another one bites the dust by the way
deputy FBI director Andrew McCabe who's
been facing pressure from Trump for
months now has stepped down in order to
get his retirement with full benefits he
will stay on the FBI payroll
conveniently for him until mid March but
not as deputy FBI director how that
works exactly I'm not sure but it's
working for him I think he has some sick
days and personal days okay good for him
Trump has been treating mccabe terribly
for a long time now we've been talking
about it we now know that in the oval
office meeting he had with mccabe after
the firing of James Comey Trump asked
McCabe who he had voted for in 2016
which is an inappropriate question then
during a phone call he told McCabe to
ask his wife what it feels like to be a
loser since she had lost the political
campaign shortly before that
conversation took place and then also
recall that back in July Donald Trump
tweeted about Andrew McCabe why didn't
attend each eneral sessions replace
acting FBI director Andrew McCabe a
Comey friend who was in charge of
Clinton investigation
McCabe has been in the FBI since 1996
he's worked under two Republican
directors of the FBI Robert Muller as
well as James Comey and naturally after
the announcement the the revelation that
Andrew McCabe would be stepping down
White House press secretary Sarah
Huckabee Sanders said Trump had nothing
to do with this the White House played
no role in the resignation of Andrew
McCabe and she referred future questions
to the FBI now right away minute seconds
even after this news broke you had
committed trumpets saying McCabe is
stepping aside because the FISA memo
once it's released is just going to
crush him and I kind of pretended to buy
into that yesterday I guess I was a
little too convincing because I jokingly
tweeted I believe the deputy FBI
director stepped down because he knew
he'd be fired as soon as the contents of
the memo were released I also believe
Donald Trump is six foot three inches
tall and weighs 239 pounds and a pair
a lot of people only read that first
sentence and thought I was serious and I
was saying oh yeah the the memo was
going to lead to his firing so I got out
early you're trolling the trolls I'm
trolling no question about it so let's
break this down into its component parts
since there's really a lot to think
about here first of all did Donald Trump
push Andrew McCabe out directly or
indirectly I don't know but I argue I
would argue that it's not hugely
relevant that the firing of James Comey
and the order to fire Robert Muller and
the pressure on Jeff Sessions to get rid
of McCabe if there is going to be a
charge of obstruction then I don't think
we even need to figure out whether or
not and the cabe actually was pressured
to step down by anyone than Trump
administration I think it becomes
secondary or even tertiary to an
obstruction yeah and I think it's
definitely possible that McCabe was just
used to flying under the radar and he
didn't like being in the public
spotlight he didn't like his wife being
in the public spotlight and usually
would make it out once he could yes so I
think that that discussion while
interesting is not hugely relevant to
any possible upcoming charges related to
obstruction now along those same lines
McCabe was two months from retirement
one way or the other and there was every
expectation he was going to step down
resign quit retire in March anyway the
McCabe replacement is actually very
interesting because FBI director
Christopher ray has chosen David Bowdich
or Bowditch I'm not exactly sure how
it's pronounced to replace Andrew McCabe
and once again Bowditch is the type that
Republicans by profile should love he's
a former police officer he was a sniper
on SWAT teams he was on the JTTF the
Joint Terrorism Task Force he fought
against gangs he is the epitome of the
law and order guy that Trump claims to
love but from everything I've read
Bowditch is arguably even worse for
Trump and McCabe because from every
indication everything I've read so far
he's not going to take any of Trump's
crap period so I think that this will be
very interesting to see and again for
that reason and because obstruction
charges could
exist they could materialize regardless
of Trump's involvement or non
involvement in the resignation of McCabe
I don't think that's really the question
the question that I have is can the
Moller investigation continue
unencumbered I think we can say it
probably can right I think that in in
all in all likelihood at this point the
Moller investigation is continuing
unencumbered and you know I have no
emotional ideological attachment to
anything in particular coming out of
that investigation to be perfectly clear
even though there are there is this
cottage industry of people particularly
on the internet who want to talk about
how I have pre determined that there was
X Y or Z crime committed from an
ideological perspective I don't care
what I want is a full and unencumbered
investigation so that we can finally get
a determination on that and then we can
all move on and move on to bigger and
better things yeah just get the facts
out none of these firings and you know
trying to off you skate and yes that's
exactly what you know exactly what I am
saying send me your thoughts I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show and boy do
we have a good one for you today our
sponsor for today's episode of the David
Pakman show is brilliant org if you
watch our channel or listen to our
podcast yeah you're into politics you're
into daily news but maybe you want to
dig a little deeper on the program we
talked about climate change
taxes technology political philosophy
but if you really want to understand
these issues at the most fundamental
level you have to familiarize yourself
with what is actually underpinning all
of it and that's math and philosophy the
hard sciences and the social sciences
and that's where brilliant comes in
brilliant is a truly unique and
innovative online learning service that
allows you to master important
real-world math and science concepts
that means everything from probability
and statistics on one hand to logic and
problem solving on the other and
renewable energy and client climate
science and criminology you name it and
you can get started right the second by
signing up for free at brilliant
org slash David Pakman and the first 200
people who visit brilliant org slash
David Pakman will get 20% off an annual
premium membership one more time that is
brilliant
org slash David Pakman